frank williams where did you get the
title of your book judging lincoln it
was suggested to me by my sometime
co-author harold holzer
why because it is an in fact the
judgment of lincoln throughout his
career in that I'm a judge myself we're
in Rhode Island I serve as the chief
50th Chief Justice of the Supreme Court
of Rhode Island after serving five years
as a Superior Court trial judge where
did you first get interested in Abraham
Lincoln remember the day yes well I
remember the grade sixth grade in the
Cranston Rhode Island Public Schools
mrs. Taylor my teacher directed me
toward Lincoln and the Civil War I had
already had an interest in American
history so what was the first thing you
did about trying to know Abraham Lincoln
well it was a matter of my sitting under
this Lodge portrait of Lincoln and there
was something in his face that attracted
me I don't know whether it was the
compassion or leadership and my mother
had read stories to me from a child's
biography of Lincoln a couple of years
earlier so by the time I was 11 I was
already hooked on on the president when
did it get to be serious I think 13 when
I decided to become a lawyer because I
realized what a good attorney Lincoln
was but when in those early days did you
say I really liked this guy and for what
reason it is said almost right away at
11 because it was like the Horatio Alger
story if he could make it I could make
it my family had a modest living at the
time and we lived very modestly and and
it was sort of like what we've coined or
what Gabor bourret is coined the right
to rise if he could make it I could make
it you say in your book that he was a
lawyer a practicing lawyer for 24 years
before he became a politician actually
he was both a politician and a lawyer he
was a politician before he became an
attorney but he had those two careers
that were inextricably entwined how many
cases did he find before a court well we
think 5,000 cases as it as a lawyer on
the circuit or in Springfield and over
333 appeal
in the Illinois Supreme Court which is
an amazing number of Appeals did he ever
make any money yes he did more than most
people know you know 5,000 case 5,000
for one case the Illinois Central case
with it which was a tax case he saved
the he saved the railroad Millions what
he ever do with his money by the way
Lincoln did not have to quote his last
law partner Billy Herndon he did not
have the avarice to get but he had the
avarice to keep very conservative and he
kept most of his money or saved it now
if you buy your book and it's published
by the Southern Illinois University
Press right what do you get well you get
a number of things you get nine essays
that based on lectures that I've given
since 1984 in many areas collecting
Lincoln as commander-in-chief attorney
in chief how I culture views him his
growth as a man and a leader and you get
to see a good portion of some of the
things in the Frank and Virginia
Williams collection of Lincoln iana some
49 illustrations which is a large number
I think for a press to put in a book I
do notice somewhere I did notice that
you're one of the big five of the
Lincoln collectors well I don't know
about the number but it is a big
collection some 12,000 books and
pamphlets 10,000 other items prints
photographs statuary philately
numismatics photographs and maybe
another 20,000 clippings which you can
use as a resource in this research
library but you say that you're still
30% void you don't have 30% of material
need 30% of the first 500 items in the
monahan bibliography which came out in
1939 and are the most difficult items
sometimes one page or a small pamphlet
to get but remember Brian since
Lincoln's life because there were works
about him during his life and a half
his death there have been over 17,000
books pamphlets and articles written
about Lincoln so what could you possibly
say in this book that would be new well
it would be my interpretation of the man
and the leader I'm fascinated by the
leadership issue and how he operated as
a president and many times you know I
wonder about this in my own position as
a judge how you would face crises and
you know I have them we all have them in
leadership positions and and it's a
great comfort to me to know that here's
a man who is the quintessential American
from humble beginnings only one years
education in blab schools who could rise
to become the president of the United
States and lead us through Civil War I
asked this question for the obvious
reason because most of what you saying
here is positive is there anything about
Abraham Lincoln you don't like yes
because each of us have a dark side and
a light side and Lincoln had a dark side
too he had a temper most people don't
know that fortunately for us and himself
he was able to keep it in check most of
the time I think his views on race are
ambivalent at best and racist at worst
and of course this is the culture in
which he lived and we see that of course
in comments he made at the
lincoln-douglas debates but as other
scholars have said he probably would not
have won the race for president if he
had taken a position more closely
aligned to the abolitionists do you ever
feel in all you read that people who
like Abraham Lincoln kind of dismiss
this stuff and they end up saying yeah
he was he wasn't a perfect man but but
in the end he did great things well you
know I think that's that's true in past
generations but I think in our current
generation there's there's more a sense
of reality that Lincoln really was not a
godlike figure that he was a human being
and he was raised to the heavens after
his death which is unfortunate he
shouldn't be treated as some kind of a
votive candle on the shelf somewhere and
that he did have he did have human
foibles he was a hypochondria
he was suspicious he misjudged his
generals during the war until he himself
developed the necessary judgment to to
retain generals that could win battles
but this is all part of the growth I
think of a human being in the first
instance and a leader in the second we
asked our Richard Hall our photographer
who works a lot on the book area to go
to your home for very soon they're gonna
see for obvious reasons where do you
live well sure I live in I live in
southern Rhode Island Inn in Hope Valley
near the Connecticut border and if
somebody comes to visit here how much
Lincoln are they gonna say well they're
going to see a great deal the more
valuable material I keep in the vault of
course for obvious reasons many of the
prints Statuary many of the books
Lincoln books and and I think we're
about to go into the Lincoln library
there's another library called Civil War
and collateral this is the front hallway
with Lincoln prints and cartoons I I'm
I'm very much infatuated with editorial
cartoonist and they're always of course
using Lincoln as a foil where we go
we're now going down to the Civil War
and collateral collection this is all in
your home all in my home how many items
about 12,000 and is this under guard yes
and there's a Doberman there too what
what are we looking at here this is you
just past Rogers groups who was a great
John with sculpture of Lincoln's day and
you're looking at a place that needs
more bookshelves for one thing there's
Ennis and of course you see books on
carousels and carriages which represent
projects that I'm working on why are you
doing this doing collecting well because
I think it's an important legacy it's
not only helped me research but
something that Virginia and I can leave
some data was school which has none
which has no Lincoln in Civil War
collection what's the predominance of
this collection of course its its
Abraham Lincoln books and pamphlets
and it is cataloged as you can see we
started cataloging it before there was a
software program for computers whoever
gets the collection will have to do the
scanning what would you say the value of
this is in dollars if you were able to
sell it oh I wouldn't have a clue as I
said I think so at least a million this
is the tack room where Bob our Doberman
lives most of the time and we have what
Virginia collects achieve jaws and Jim
cracks this is presentation copy of the
lincoln-douglas debates that's our book
plate made from an engraving from Fritz
Eichenberg which adorns the cover of
judging Lincoln what's the most you've
ever paid for anything $40,000 this is
the presentation from Lincoln to mrs.
Spencer you know how proud he was of the
lincoln-douglas debates even though he
lost the Senate race in 58 this was a
John Rogers group council of war with
grant on the left and Staunton on the
right Robert Lincoln thought this was
the best likeness of his father is this
a copy
no it's an original this this is a kata
physique you know those small visiting
cards that that were very common in
during the Civil War with John Wilkes
Booth and with the devil looking over
his shoulder this is a pass to the
military commission that tried the
conspirators signed by general hunter
and of course a campaign flag noticed
the misspelling of Lincoln's first name
abram for Abraham what was what was
worth $40,000 a rare array a pamphlet in
book this this is a original oil
painting by James Montgomery Flagg a
great illustrator and painter of the
early part of the 20th century he's
known mostly for creating the I want you
Uncle Sam poster the
is a miniature painting of a beardless
lincoln on ivory by an artist by the
name of Paterson done about 1929 this is
a wide-awake lanten you recall during
the 1860 election there were these great
wide-awake parades in favor of the
Republican ticket and people would carry
them over their shoulder of course mrs.
Lincoln in better times with the with
the beautiful dress that she's wearing
this is a photograph from Brady studio
there was a tax on these photographs
that's why you see the stamp this is one
of the great things that I keep in the
bank vault Lincoln's telegram to a
lawyer friend Samuel Glover in st. Louis
and he's asking for news of what's going
on intelligence and all during the war
you would get messages from Lincoln what
news this is the first autograph of
Lincoln that I ever purchased the Year
1970 you're looking at this isn't really
directly to Lincoln but these are the
combat ribbons from my regiment that I
served with in Germany the 2nd Armored
Cavalry Regiment they started in the
Mexican War as the second dragoons and
that last oil was also by James
Montgomery Flagg you were in the
military when 62 to 67 three years on
the border between East and West Germany
in the second cavalry and one year in
Vietnam as an infantry advisor in
1966-67 what impacted the military have
onion a great deal of impact I Brian I
don't think I would have been half the
lawyer or the judge trial judge or chief
justice if I had not had the experience
of in the United States Army were you
steeped in Abraham Lincoln when you're
in the service I was because I had
already been studying them a great deal
of course when you're overseas the
collecting sort of takes a backseat to
to your duties but what about his
military leadership you write a lot
about that and there's a relationship
with the generals in your book that
that's important to me because of course
the president is commander-in-chief as
well as chief magistrate of America and
his role in both
passage was was important for me to
study and I'm pleased with the way he
managed on the whole with with these
dual roles he struggled mightily as
every president does as this current
president is doing many of the issues
that Lincoln had we now have now that we
at will we are at war with terrorism the
security of our country versus civil
liberties and there's an essay they are
on Lincoln and civil liberties during
wartime so that's why Lincoln remains
such a relevant person in our current
life what year were you in Vietnam
SiC 1966 and 67 Lyndon Johnson was
president did you ever say anything
about if Abraham Lincoln were here today
he wouldn't do what this president has
done not then but since that time I you
know we followed orders and went I
wondered we many of us veterans wonder
why we were there in the first place and
why President Johnson and his
administration did not have the courage
to get us out before we incurred 58,000
deaths of our service people all the
pictures in your book in your collection
yes they are
who is this general McClellan Raia Raia
pose Lincoln's troublesome General who
he's who he had become commander in
chief initially he was not he had a case
of the slows to quote Lincoln he
reinstated him as General after the
Second Battle of Bull Run and after
Antietam when when McClellan refused to
follow up the so called victory Lincoln
finally had the courage to fire him
remember McClellan was very popular with
his troops how did he fire him he sent a
messenger with an order relieving him
from command and appointing Ambrose
Burnside a Rhode Islander to take his
place as commanding general of the Army
of the Potomac and of course Burnside
did not want the command he knew he
didn't have the competence for it and of
course we saw that at the Battle of
Fredericksburg in December 1862 what was
difference in age between Abraham
Lincoln and George McClellan Lincoln was
older remember he was 51 when he was
elected and and McClellan was somewhat
younger than that
how did McClellan end up running against
him in 64 for the presidency well the
Democrats are the loyal opposition
thought that since he was so popular
with the troops and America he was an
icon with many lithographs and Prince of
McClellan hanging in Union home or homes
in the North they chose him as the
Democratic candidate for president in
1864 but there was a conflict of Brian
from the beginning here there they're
making this this former commanding
general of the Army of the Potomac the
Democratic candidate but then the peace
lovers acquired a peace platform in
which in which there would be an effort
at peace without without the end of
slavery without necessarily reunion and
this doomed the Democrats in the 1864
election did was George McClellan in the
service way around he came back in the
service he had been in the service
earlier a West Point graduate then
became an executive for the railroad and
then came back into the service at the
time of the Civil War like so many
people Burnside General Grant Oh what
became general grannie started as a
colonel of a regiment in illinois but in
64 head he get out of the service
terrain he was out he was really
relieved of duties and even though he
held the rank and he returned home to
New Jersey he never received an act of
command again what's this in your book
well that is that is a campaign
lithograph of general McClellan for the
1864 campaign and his vice presidential
candidate Pendleton from Ohio you have
the actual figures in the book to how
many people voted you I've got him here
you say that Abraham Lincoln won 22 of
25 states yes and Dominion this is the
64 yes
2,200,000 for him and 1,800,000 against
him what did that mean when that
happened in that at that time well you
know that that's an excellent question
because you know Lincoln is sometimes
criticized for Curt curtailing civil
liberties like suspending the writ of
habeas corpus we could talk about that
forever but here's a president in a
commander-in-chief that allows the
elections to go forward in wartime and
initially you know in 64 he thought he
was going to lose that's why he wrote
the blind memorandum in August and had
all of the cabinet members initial the
back of it that he expected to lose and
if he did he would work with the
incoming president to terminate the war
or prevail in the war sort of the fact
that elections were held the soldiers
and there's an essay about the soldier
vote in this book this was the first
time in American history that soldiers
in the field were allowed to cast the
ballot so he took a big gamble and yet
he believed in the basic tenets of a
democracy that you should not curtail
this necessity of having elections every
two years you say that George McClellan
was very popular with it soldiers yes
but that Abraham Lincoln in the field
vote alone not the absentee ballots got
a hundred and twenty one thousand one
hundred and fifty two votes to
McClellan's thirty four thousand nine
hundred and twenty-two that's correct
how did he how did he get that kind of
popularity because because this was the
this was the ability of Abraham Lincoln
to transcend politics and to strike a
responsive chord in many Americans
including the soldiers in the field
these were the people who were being
sent into battle receiving the
casualties and and the deaths of course
that followed and yet they believed in
and this person they they came to call
father Abraham and they were able to
differentiate between him and McClellan
who under the peace platform would end a
war that they fought so hard to prevail
you also report that 78% of the Union
soldiers cast their vote for Abraham
Lincoln all over all and that 53% of the
civilians cast a vote for a grant
correct and so you see the dichotomy and
how much support that Lincoln had in the
field the fact that that the
the soldier vote was so overwhelming for
Lincoln but did not you know affect the
outcome it probably would have affected
the state tallies in two states I think
Connecticut in New York but but what it
symbolized this is just how much Lincoln
was appreciated by the soldiers and the
soldiers in the field
what about colonization you suggest that
he was promoting every I'm Lincoln was
promoting colonization either Africa or
South America red blacks in the middle
of this election
well yes but he you know he evolved in
to the point where he finally realized
that colonization was was not going to
work
and remember colonization or that policy
of sending African Americans back to
their homes started way back with Henry
Clay and Henry Clay was the perennial
presidential candidate in a hero of
Lincoln's both were Whigs before the
Republican Party was created and this
was their way of saying look this is
going to avoid this dissension and the
arguments between the sections of the
country and also between those who are
free and those who are enslaved but as
Lincoln learned it was a wake-up call
that these blacks did not want to return
to some colony or to Africa America was
now they home and we had to deal with
them oh he had to deal with them as part
of our culture in the 1860 election what
was the percentage of vote that Abraham
Lincoln got about 39% Bryan how many
candidates were there they were four and
in the 1864 election how many candidates
were there were just two that I call
Fremont you know who was the first
Republican candidate in 1856 almost went
ahead and and became another candidate
against Lincoln but the politicos or the
Republican Party operatives work that
out so that Fremont would not become a
candidate it took the firing of Blair
from the cabinet to take care of that
who was Blair Blair was the Postmaster
General why why did it take the firing
because there was dissension between the
Radical
Republicans in the conservative
Republicans who did not get along and
the politics as you can imagine were
pretty intense even even among
Republicans and also on the voting side
you say that the absentee ballot was
first introduced in the in 1862 in
Wisconsin correct the absentee ballots
in all of our elections correct and what
happened after they started how many
other states would do it all but a
couple of states including my own Rhode
Island did not have the absentee ballot
but a what is it with Rhode Island and
the founding of this country and they're
you know they're they were they were not
great participants and well very
important and it starts with Roger
Williams nor relation who either left it
was thrown out of the Massachusetts Bay
Colony because he wanted to practice
religion the way he believed it should
be practiced and that's why we have
really a Rhode Island became such a
refuge for every religion Jewish the
first the first congregation of Jews in
Newport Rhode Island and the fact that
we became ornery and very independent
and we and I'm proud of the fact that we
are because on May 4 1776 two months
before Philadelphia Rhode Island issued
its own declaration of independence from
Great Britain which took a lot of guts
again we participated in the in the
Continental Congress but we would not
send we would not send a delegation to
the Constitution convention in 1787
because we were afraid of a strong
national government and George
Washington was not happy with us we were
mostly in agrarian economy building into
a textile industry with our own
Industrial Revolution and we were afraid
of a strong power and that and that's
and that exists even today even to this
day I think is it is there a way to
describe Rhode Island's politics heavily
Democratic yet we have a Republican
governor and I think independent by the
voter I think I think like
the soldiers and country related to
Lincoln I think I Rhode Islanders relate
to the honesty and character of a
statewide officer as the Chief Justice
of the Rhode Island Supreme Court is a
call Supreme Court of Superior Court
Supreme Court Supreme Court did you run
on a party label no we have a modified
Missouri plan which is selection by
merit and you you have an independent
commission a Judicial Nominating
Commission that goes through your
application interviews public hearing
background criminal checks sends three
to five names to the governor he does
the same thing and in the case of
Supreme Court appointments he sends one
to both the House and Senate for
independent hearings and then if they
provide advice and consent like the
federal government you're sworn in for
life or bad behavior which for whichever
first occurs do you consider yourself a
Republican or Democrat I grew up as a
Republican but became very very
independent and during my during my law
practice I'm proud to say I was
unanimously confirmed by an overwhelming
House and Senate Democratic majority so
you have a label on your now or you
still own oh I
you give all that up you don't you don't
really participate in partisan politics
at all I think it's good i I I'm not
that keen on election of judges and I
I'd like to see us get away from it
those in the states where they have
election of judges may feel differently
where'd you get your law degree Boston
University School of Law how about your
underground the same except it was the
College of Liberal Arts before I went
into the service now when did you start
in the like the Abraham Lincoln
Association when did you get involved in
that and what is it well actually
actually Brian I really started in in
Lincoln organizations as a senior in
undergraduate school and when I when I
attended meetings of the Lincoln group
of Boston and of course I was very
passionate about Lincoln at the time and
I eventually became president then I
became a member of the board of
directors of the Abraham Lincoln
Association which is located in
Springfield Illinois
serving for nine years as president I
left as president after nine years and
then with with the encouragement of many
Lincoln people on the East Coast we we
began what's called the Lincoln Forum
that meets every November in Gettysburg
from November 16 to 18 dovetailing into
november 19th which is the anniversary
of Lincoln's Gettysburg Address whatever
happened between the American I mean the
Abraham Lincoln Association and your
group well it really wasn't between my
group the the Lincoln Forum which came
after there was a disagreement in my
leadership and I was not re-elected in
1995 and there were many board members
that that resigned there was a feeling
by many of us that the Association
really more concentrated more on the
local area of Springfield and a little
Illinois where some of us and I was a
leader in this that wanted the outreach
of the study of Lincoln and include
other Lincoln groups to make us the
umbrella and to disseminate and study
about Abraham Lincoln John Y Simon from
Southern Illinois University says in in
the guess the conclusion in this book
that you were brought in to be a part of
the Lincoln industry the only thing I'm
getting out here is the word industry
what is the Lincoln industry well it's
everything the collecting the studying
the writing the lecturing the
conferences that we put together and of
course there is this core group whether
it's in Springfield or Gettysburg or the
Lincoln group of the District of
Columbia or the Lincoln fellowship of
Wisconsin there is this this group that
that really make up the industry just
like Cobb there's a called Sandburg
industry because of all the writings
that he that he did and poetry that he
did he composed how big is it how many
people are involved well I suppose if
you say the bragging bragging rights if
you wanted to use that several thousand
but for hardcore I would say under a
thousand so for hardcore Lincoln Heights
here we come with a this event in
Springfield with the opening of a
library and a museum how important is
that to the industry well I think it's
important because Lincoln does not have
a Presidential Library there certainly
was none in his day or at the time of
his passing in 1865 so it's good to see
a librarian museum that's that's devoted
to him and his works but will that
change I think it will change the
ability of people to study him and to
have more ready access to him than
heretofore
and what will the difference will that
make well that's the hope that's the
whole point the whole point is to tell
the to tell the Lincoln story not to
embellish it but to have the resources
there for people who really want to
discern the truth to be able to do that
rather than the perception so you were
president of the Abraham Lincoln
Association now president of the Lincoln
forum and also co-chairman of the
Abraham Lincoln Bicentennial Commission
Bicentennial his dad I reserved his
birth know I'm a member of the Abraham
the u.s. Abraham Lincoln Bicentennial
Commission Harold Holt sir senator
Richard Durbin and congressman Ray
LaHood are the co-chairs there are 15 of
us that are commissioners we've created
an advisory board of about a hundred to
assist in the planning for the
celebration of Lincoln's 200th birthday
on February 12 2009 how much time goes
into that not not a lot I think as we as
we organize into into committees and
begin the grunt work of what
publications there should be what is our
constituency reaching across the seas
like we did in 1959 on one hundred and
fiftieth reaching into schools to assist
the teachers and the students with a
core curriculum they will it will take
more and more time we just retained an
executive director Michael Bishop fine
historian
and very energized and and I hope that
this will be a big help in our
organization how many times often do you
meet as a commission at least two or
three times a year but I think that's
going to increase and what kind of
people keep participating in all this
well as commissioners you've got
historians and and Lincoln people
historians like Professor Jim Horton who
you know from hard Wars George
Washington and of course Gabor boric
from the Civil War Institute at
Gettysburg College Harold Holzer we all
know was a peripatetic author and
founder of the Lincoln group of New York
and we have Joan Flynn's pas who is the
president and CEO of the Lincoln Museum
in Fort Wayne Indiana Dara Darryl Begum
from from Indiana who really heads our
education subcommittee so you have you
have a wide variety judge Tommy Turner
from Hodgenville who's Kentucky who's
very active where is born right exactly
when Lincoln was born and of course he
Tommy Turner was very it was very much
responsible for turning over one of the
Lincoln boyhood homes to the National
Park Service this year Knob Creek which
is just a few miles from Hodgenville now
go back to the collecting chapter in
here and your involvement how many books
not not pamphlets but books have been
written about every I must say about
13,000 is well how does that fit with
all the other human beings in this case
well you know it used to be Jesus Christ
Napoleon and Abraham Lincoln I'm not
sure about that anymore
I think Abraham Lincoln may be the
leader on books for any historical
figure in your chapter you talk about
Malcolm Forbes having a big impact on
the collecting world he did who was he
and when did it start well you know
Malcolm Forbes was the publisher of
Forbes magazine now deceased and in the
70s he began collecting Lincoln
assiduously he had been a collector of
many other things like Faberge Easter
eggs miniature led soldiers
and he acquired fortune in Lincoln
documents many of which was sold this
last much by his heirs or the Forbes
family at Christie's and the second
auction of his presidential collection
not just Lincoln but material relating
other presidents will will take place in
October of this year by Christie's so
what was that first purchase that
started this well well it was this
nature it was this letter to major
ramsay by lincoln and you can tell
lincoln sense of humor and character and
i'm paraphrasing now of course because i
don't have in front of him in front of
me but he's writing a major ramsey and
he says this this woman wants to work
see if you can find her a job wining the
work is so rare and event it ought to be
encouraged did he write all this in
longhand yes he did did he dictate to
anybody
he may have dictated a few times to his
secretaries john Nicolay and john hay
but most of this was done in his own
hand by him now after Malcolm for view
says Ross Perot got in the act they
competed that I remember one event where
they were competing over a printed copy
printed now not not holographic not in
not in Lincoln's handwriting on a copy
of the Emancipation Proclamation that
was signed by Lincoln and his Secretary
of State William Seward
I think it's sold for two hundred and
seventy thousand dollars what's the
minimum it would cost you today to get
an Abraham Lincoln signature well if you
were to get that that klipse signature
that we saw on the monitor which was my
first Lincoln document went for $200 in
1970 I think to get one like it is today
would be five thousand dollars and and
remember people in olden days thought
that by clipping the signature from the
document would would make more value to
the signature which of course is
ridiculous because you really want the
whole document so what about today if
somebody wants to get into this
collecting business you've got to have a
lot of money well yes
many don't have including institutions
libraries but but the hope that McNeely
and I try to portray in the chapter on
collecting is that you don't need to
collect everything you don't need to
have wealth to get Lincoln documents you
can start modestly campaign documents
Prince cots divisie the photographs the
little photographs sheet music coins
anything that that represents the the
middle period of American history and of
course has a story to say about about
Abraham Lincoln you also have a lot of
Abraham Lincoln or some Abraham Lincoln
in your chambers at the court I do is
there a reason for that I mean well in a
signal one is that one is that I like
having them around me and second it's an
inspiration to me during my own days at
work now on the screen we have the court
yes where as this is the provenance
county and Supreme Court of Rhode Island
in in Providence this is the this is the
conference room where me and the other
four justices of the Supreme Court
deliberate after we hear oral arguments
and when we have conferences during the
month is there any Abraham Lincoln oh I
want to spare my colleagues this is the
beautiful appellate court room the Rhode
Island Supreme Court one of the most
beautiful appellate court rooms in the
country this was all built in the 1930s
during the Depression Brian with with
cash no bond money any Lincoln in this
room no where do you start putting
Lincoln in your court act it would be in
my in my office for Mike law clerks and
assistant and mostly in my chambers does
everybody know that you're a Lincoln
they do follow her they knew this long
before I was a lawyer of course this is
this is my chambers
or the Chief Justice's chambers I'm only
the temporary occupant and you can see
some Lincoln in the background I open
that bust of Lincoln which is a copy of
the Volk bust I've had since I was 13
years old I'm especially enamored with
these maquettes these small
copies of Lincoln this is John hey and
John Nicolaes biography of Lincoln first
reading of the Emancipation Proclamation
a working model of Daniel Chester French
is Lincoln for the Lincoln Memorial
don't mind the chef's hat that was given
to me by Roger Williams University for a
Lincoln lecture this is a full-scale
model of Lincoln's patent that's in the
US Patent Office Lincoln's idea of
lifting a vessel over the shoals with
those ballast that are underneath the
the deck this is a presentation copy by
the free colored people of New Orleans
to President Lincoln in honor of his
issuing the Emancipation Proclamation
now when somebody goes in front of you
in the court do they ever try to slip in
quotes from here yes they do and to the
amusement of me and my colleagues but we
appreciate that it's not going to make a
tinker's damn in the way that the case
comes out but it's it's it's something
to break up let's say the oral argument
now in you're collecting chapter you
have these two what what is this right
here
well that's Jeff Davis and it's it's
really an editorial cartoon that works
with a sliding thing at the bottom and
you see him happy in that on the Left as
I face you because the Fort Sumter has
has fallen and then you see him you you
move the the little slip underneath to
the frown on the right side and he's
frowning because the Confederacy just
lost Vicksburg to General Grant of all
the things you've collected what's your
favorite I think my favorite is that
presentation copy that we saw on the
monitor of the lincoln-douglas debates
signed by by Lincoln you've mentioned a
couple times the Emancipation
Proclamation and then in the book you
write a lot about the 13th amendment I
do one of the more interesting things to
me about the 13th amendment is that you
talk about Abraham Lincoln trading votes
bribing to get the 13th amendment pass
first of all what's the 13th amendment
of course the 13th amendment outlawed
involuntary servitude to use the exact
language slavery for
forever and was added to the
Constitution at the end of 1865 but
Lincoln campaigned for this amendment
long before the re-election in 64 which
took a lot of guts and courage he didn't
have to say anything but he he did
campaign for it and it was so important
to him that he lag rolled used patronage
we never found any any illegal acts that
he may have committed to get votes but
the important thing Brian is he wanted
the old Congress that is the Congress
that would go out of existence after his
inauguration in 1865 to be the one to
pass the resolution that would go to the
states for ratification and he succeeded
in February 1865 you write about the
bribery statute though yes and that that
that it's a close call on whether his
offer of patronage to congressmen to get
their vote ran afoul of an anti bribery
statute that was already part of the
United States Code how far did he go
very close we think no money but clearly
the implication that if if you were to
vote for this resolution you might be
taken care of with one of your
constituents or relatives being given a
job and the government when did the 13th
amendment passed December of 65 buy
enough states to make it part of the
Constitution but in February of 65 by
the House and Senate to send to the
States for ratification what was the
letter between Abraham Lincoln and Jeff
Davis back in February of 65 he died in
April yes and he was reelected in
November yes and so we're in between
there what was that exchange where
something about slaves I remember
writing it down do you know I'm talking
about I think it's I think it's the the
fear that Lincoln or the interest that
Lincoln may have had in bringing the war
to closure and there was an issue on
whether the the primary object was to
reunify the north and south and I think
the issue between Lincoln and the peace
delegation that came
Hampton Roads with Vice President
Alexander Stevens of the Confederacy as
whether or not it would be reunion with
slavery or without slavery and Lincoln
held to the view that the war aims were
now reunion and no slavery on your back
time jumping around here but on your
collections chapter the forgery of the
Ann Rutledge letters what year was that
that was in the 20s in the Atlantic
Monthly and there were award 20s one day
sir and it was ostensibly well it
purported to show this love affair
between Ann Rutledge and Abraham Lincoln
you know there's been an issue ever
since her death and this was a New Salem
romance where Lincoln spent over six
years in the 1830s and she was engaged
to another man who really left to come
back east and deserted her died and
people have always questioned whether or
not this was a true romance between
Abraham Lincoln and her and these
letters that were forged attempted to
show that there was but of course they
have no credibility at all here's a
photo in the book of a controversial
Clement the Landingham from Ohio a
copperhead one who was active in the
Democratic Party he was a Democratic
congressman who vociferously opposed the
war and of course the curtailment of
civil liberties by Lincoln especially
the suspension of the writ of habeas
corpus you know that's where an
imprisoned person has the right to
appear before a magistrate to check why
you're in prison there has to be
probable cause and some crime alleged
and of course during the war Lincoln
with the ratification of Congress
suspended the precious writ of habeas
corpus
what's the Copperhead Copperhead is
euphemism or metaphor for the snake of
the the same name and this is the loyal
the loyal unionists called these peace
Democrats copperheads those who would
meet secretly and
protests an object to the government so
Clement Laird the Landingham was from
what state Ohio and was what office to
the old congressman how vociferous was
his opposition it was it was very vocal
and very vicious and to Lincoln's credit
he would not move against him because of
the First Amendment you allow dissension
but Ambrose Burnside after
Fredericksburg was sent to the
department in Ohio and he had a captain
dressed in civilian clothes go to a
speech where the Landingham held forth
and Burnside had issued a general order
that made it reasonable to utter
utterances against the government he had
him arrested he was tried by a military
tribunal he was to be he was to be
sentenced for a long term in prison it
embarrassed Lincoln Lincoln had the
Landingham sent in the into the
Confederate lines
the Confederates weren't that happy to
have landing him he finally left by way
of Bermuda and landed in Canada and ran
for the Governor of Ohio from Canada
unsuccessfully so what would happen if
this if President did this today well
look what's happening right now where
this administration is planning for
military tribunals some day and look at
the objections by many liberals and
other people who are against the use of
military tribunals even non-citizens of
the United States that's why there's
about 600 in Guantanamo Bay what's your
own personal feeling about that there is
a place for military tribunals in this
kind of a war as long as there's due
process and there are not summary
executions I think to require federal
trials is that that's the forum in which
these combatants or unlawful combatants
or detainees as they're called in
Guantanamo if they would be in the
federal system I think it would it would
bring great risk to
the security of jurors and also affect
intelligence not to mention the
logistical problems that our judicial
system would have when you think of how
long the trial was for World Trade
Center one there's a place for them
where is this from that's an unknown
artist of the Lincoln family there were
so many prints of the Lincoln family
this is an unusual one the the Lincoln's
were never photographed photography was
still in its infancy there was never a
composite photograph of the Lincoln
family so so all of the artists would
would make this composite of the of the
family this photograph that's the man
himself standing behind the fence
beardless of course with two of his
children that you see Willie and tadd
and their friend Gumpert who who is who
was fading out because he moved during
the taking of the photograph because you
were required to sit or stand still for
several minutes for the chemicals to set
on a glass plate if you moved you would
get what you just saw there and that was
a photograph from Springfield yes what
is Frank Williams the Chief Justice of
the Rhode Island Supreme Court going to
do with that collection in his basement
the plan that Virginia and I have is
that some day it will go to a school
that has no Lincoln or Civil War
collection as our legacy so that other
people more people can use it as a
resource and understanding and studying
Lincoln has anybody asked you for yes
there there have been interest by Brown
University which already has a great
Lincoln collection the McClellan Lincoln
collection he was one of the big five
after Lincoln's death Louisiana State
University in Shreveport which has a
triennial conference on the president's
and an International Lincoln Center
headed headed by Professor bill Peterson
so you
you got any instinct since the words
gonna go uh not right now because I
still need this
for my own research I'd like to begin
sending out duplicates different
printings because I'm really out of room
here at what stage in your life do you
want to give this away well I hope while
I'm still alive but if I'm not there is
a provision in my estate plan with a
committee to determine where the
collection will go when the truck pulls
up outside your home is that gonna be
hard for you no I don't think so I've
already come to terms with that you know
it's like any material item Brian you
know we're only here temporarily and
then we pass just as I'll passed the
baton for being chief justice someday to
a successor and the collection ought to
go the same way now what about in this
collection can others come into your
home and use it by appointment they can
and many have what's this from that is a
cot to visie they've called the
apotheosis because this is this is
Lincoln being received in heaven by
George Washington the father of his
country
now you say in your book that Abraham
Lincoln's hero was George Washington yes
and did he read parson Williams he did
as a youth not a very factual biography
but to a young boy to see Washington
lead the Continental Army and the story
of Valley Forge and the battles where
the Continental Army was was outnumbered
I think made a great impression on on
the young Lincoln you say in the book
that he had a feminine side every man
does the question is how strong it is
and that is that comes out in the
compassion and the way he treated other
people not just women but of course his
his contemporaries and the citizens that
he served why did you feel the need to
compare the feminine side with his mask
well I think that's pot in in in the
essay on the women in Lincoln's life and
and the influence they they may have had
on him in his development as a youth and
and a man and of course there were some
some women in Lincoln's life that were
very influential on his growth of course
his mother Nancy Hanks who died
when he was young and his stepmother
Sarah Bush Johnson Lincoln and of course
his sister Sarah who we don't hear much
about and Mary Owens who he was
supposedly engaged but they fell out of
I think love if they had love and of
course finally and the most important
woman I think in Lincoln's life was Mary
Todd his wife now every year when you
get together your groups the Lincoln
Forum and all this is there much
disagreement among people that like
Abraham Lincoln about anything well I
think so because you know you know the
fascinating part about Lincoln Bryan is
that he was an enigma that as much as we
know about him in the historical record
in his utterance --is in the collected
works of his writings and speeches
almost a million words he still kept
many things very close to his chest he
was a very private person so I think the
challenge is to try to detect what was
really going on in his mind and what his
motivations were and the Machiavellian
nature of his personality if there is
there a book today that you would
recommend to somebody who wanted to
start their process of understanding
Abraham Lincoln there are a couple
certainly the latest is David Donald's
Lincoln Benjamin Thomas wrote a great
one volume biography in the 50s Steven
Oates's biography with malice toward
none in the 70s all serve a great
purpose in trying to understand mr.
Lincoln take David Donald Lincoln book
he referenced in that book James Randall
as his hero who taught him yes Abraham
Lincoln and you talk about James Randall
in here as kind of changing the nature
of how people looked at a rancor echt
explained who he was well James James
Randall was a professor in at the
University of Illinois who wrote many
volumes about Abraham Lincoln and what
he did in shorthand is change
the study of Lincoln from the amateur to
the professional or the professional and
amatuer because he was a trained
historian and his work is still solid
today even if you might disagree with
his opinions he wrote a great book on
Lincoln in civil liberties as well along
with a four volumes set on Lincoln
Lincoln's presidency how long are you
going to stay the president of the
Lincoln forum well if I can find someone
that's willing to take the tasks I'd be
I'd be pleased to give up the mantel
but I'm having a good time now with this
great group of people who are from all
walks of life with all different
interest in Lincoln in the Civil War so
we have a great time when we get
together in Gettysburg is it just for
insiders or kind of people listening
that have never been involved any any
its spouses of those interested in
Lincoln students truck drivers
professionals academics anyone anyone
who has an interest even a smattering
What's it cost to become a member of the
Lincoln forum like $25 for a membership
how often you meeting here we meet at
this Conclave in in Gettysburg every
November as I indicated earlier and we
we publish two bulletins a year as to
what is going on in the forum and what
we're doing in the way of outreach to to
study and spread this story of about
Lincoln now finally this is a photograph
I want to ask you what is this doing in
a book on Abraham well it's a story of
you could see seated Winston Churchill
on on my right and and Franklin
Roosevelt in the center and a General
Charles de Gaulle and an opponent of his
for the Free French it's in an essay
where I compared the leadership of
Lincoln FDR and Winston Churchill and I
have to say it was probably the most
difficult essay that that I did on this
comparative leadership quickly compared
the three Lincoln Lincoln is number one
and FDR is number two
and Winston Churchill along with FDR I
would consider the the best leaders of
the 20th century why in that order
well because Lincoln has a legacy that
transcends his period
I think FDR does too but not to the
extent of Lincoln Winston Churchill was
really the savior of Britain despite his
own frailties he would like to see the
Empire of course continue and that was
not going to happen after World War Two
this is the cover of the book our guest
has been the Chief Justice of the Rhode
Island Supreme Court Frank J Williams
and the book is judging Lincoln and we
thank you very much thank you for having
me Brian